[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week beef I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from DeKalb Market Hall in Brooklyn New
York where I'm joined by local burger
legend Andrews Rica andrew is the owner
of hard times Sundays a beloved NYC food
truck which is since evolved to a pair
of brick-and-mortar locations and today
we're getting the smashed griddle
commandment from a roadside burger
expert you've seen me conquer the
perfect egg sandwich we've made together
the smash burger and today we're going
to combine the two to recreate Andrews
famed bacon egg and cheese top for xmas
burger but first things first Andrew
what is this secret to the perfect
cheeseburger in your opinion I like to
keep it simple we don't use any fancy
blend no eggs there's also agua we use
simple products simple and Reed's that
are approachable by anybody I use a
straight up Chuck it's a it's the best
part of the cow its Prime we use a
monster tater roll which is a simple
product we use regular toppings like
lettuce tomato onions caramelize the raw
bacon mushrooms jalapenos and that's
really it toppings wise I didn't hear a
lot in the name of sauces are you anti
condiment first of all we sell burgers
we don't sell pasta you put sauce on
pasta you don't put sauce on burgers
okay we put ketchup on there if you want
mayonnaise I don't really like it but a
lot of people like it so you know when I
was first on my truck I would even offer
me people would ask right they were
right reviews they were refusing me
about mayonnaise so I get a lot [ __ ] and
I'm just going to put mayonnaise in
packets people come up the older burger
you want my own here okay here's the
packet I throw it at and I go over there
and put it on because I don't want you
to put on okay I want to smell it look
at it or see it let them know Andrew
that's the way it is listen that's
there's a place with the golden arches
like this they have a slogan if old have
it your way
here at angel roadside slice again hard
Andrews will have in my way that's my
slogan what do you make of this gourmet
burger movement $30 burgers as I was
building my first burger restaurant I
went to every single place that's
supposed to be the best burger this
gourmet burger that it will [ __ ] suck
in my opinion it doesn't need to be a
burger is not meant to be gourmet uh-huh
it wasn't developed to be gourmet it
was a comfort food it was probably
people that didn't have a lot of money
they got the ground beef I was left over
from steaks and then what people are
going to afford it they made burgers up
keep it that way keep it simple stupid
despite your animosity towards the
gourmet burgers you do have one burger
the breakfast burger that is Instagram
friendly it's one of your most popular
menu items what's the story behind that
one you know I started doing breakfast
in my burger spot in Manhattan and
people kept asking me well can you put
an egg on the burger like no like well
you serve breakfast you have eggs
obviously you can do it I says I sell
breakfast I have eggs no I'm not putting
it on your burger so after being abused
a little bit after so many people asking
me put the [ __ ] egg on the breaking a
lot I'm going to make a smaller bigger
flatter burger I'm going to put it on a
breakfast roll and I'll put a burger on
my egg and not an egg on my burger we'll
put some bacon and cheese and that's
close to a gourmet or to an egg on my
burger that you're ever going to get all
right well I'm sold
I'm starving Andrew let's get back in
the kitchen and make that breakfast
let's do it let's do it all right we're
back in the kitchen you have some bacon
on the griddle what's the next step the
next step is to have a nice hot dirty
griddle you know where I'm going with
this right that's a secret you want to
keep it just a little bit dirty right a
little bit dirty exactly the way I like
my women hot in their night one night
worth to live on nice and hot we're
going to get our pan nice and hot over
here to make our eggs we'll get our
burgers thought at first we have about a
quarter of a pound we drop that on the
grill and then that's just a ground
chuck right that's just the ground chuck
a little salt little pepper there's
about 25 percent fat in there it's
trying to chop so depending on where the
animal came from in a season it could be
anywhere from 23 to 27 percent fat we
give it a little flash in the grill and
smashing
it's real quick on the flipping on the
smash or I'm making a smash burger right
can you talk us through the technique
well when we put the burger on the grill
we turn it over because now the other
side is cooked a little bit as a little
grease on it so when we go to smash it
with this it won't stick to this so
that's the only reason why we flip it
one now it's flat it has salt on the
other side that we did before we put
some salt on this side and that's ready
that's cooking nice and ready to go
because you know we do a sunny-side-up
egg now at this point in time and we
leave a sunny-side up at this point in
time it won't stay that way but it will
fan out a little salt and pepper there
you always going to solve a pepper
everything little action this guy's
probably about ready to flip at this
moment what you want to see now see how
the blood is coming up to the top that's
I know it's ready to let you know it's
ready to flip
you turn it although the beautiful sear
and the crust on it you want to sear
because it C is in all the juices the
reason why we use a flat top is so that
it cooks in its own juices and it's an
even heat and if here's the meat evenly
so while that's melting this is cooking
we want to make sure that all of the
white clear snotty looking crap is
cooked through before we flip it Andrew
do you have any cheese rules is there
one kind of cheese that you use to use
multiple kinds of cheese but no no no no
we use American cheese and American
cheese only there is nothing that melts
like American cheese just about
everybody likes American cheese not
everybody like Swiss not everybody likes
cheddar but American it appeals to the
masses so now we're going to turn it
over at this point now it's just an
overeasy egg so now we take another
slice of cheese and with this cheese you
break the yolk we break the old and put
the cheese on there I'm basically going
to turn that off right now why do you
break the yolk well I know I want it to
be a little messy but not too messy
all right Andrew what's the deal with
this roll tell me about this roll well
this is classic so what I grew up on in
the old school lunch and that's from
Brooklyn
it's a poppy seed kaiser roll not many
people make them anymore but I have a
bakery in Brooklyn that makes it special
for me every day it's what I remember I
can taste it just when I think about it
so I knew that this was going to be the
right type of bread to put my breakfast
burger on we'll take our burger which
should be about medium or Irish
we put that on them we'll take our
over-medium eggs put that right on us
and here is your bacon get to get a
little extra butter on the roll you
always going to make sure the whole roll
is butted this way the first bite is
exactly the same as the left and they
Pro take Andrew pro tip
pro tip number one and two everybody
must be exactly the same the bacon
covers the whole sandwich da and the
burger BAM so ready to go right now this
is going to be a beautiful Explo of
America that cross-section
look at that cross-section let's hold
the top into this and that thing is
beauty Oh idiom rare a thing of beauty
take a look
[Music]
that's the ticket
Andrew that is heavenly sausage bacon
you're on notice ground chuck deserves a
place in the pantheon of breakfast
sandwiches it's sacred I'm going to
finish this I could eat about four of
these I think
[Music]